hate you oh it's a goin you know just
hanging here it don't like the rest of
everyone out there right fames same
chillin yeah not much going on here
anymore I know how is quarantine mode
for the two of you especially I mean
you're still newlyweds technically a
year and a half but I think two years
I don't know it's fun it's fun we have
to we have to find our own personal
space sometimes yeah yeah it's it's we
moved into my apartment after the show
so it's a lot smaller than the house
would have been but I think it's a much
better location so it helps keep us busy
and gives us stuff to do like let me go
walk our dog it's not super isolated
which is nice
I know it's funny that you have to find
like okay ways to keep busy structured
some sense of normalcy and then yet
you're with your partner 24/7 which is
lovely but yes I have to find your swing
time
what do you guys enjoy doing together
but what do you also enjoy doing
separately uh together our really big
thing that's actually like it's helped
us through fights and everything is
pokemons yeah we play pokemons together
a lot and it helps get us tickets moving
it's something we can do separately I
like to read I'm like just romance
novels and Matt I like video games maybe
too many video games she wasn't that she
didn't realize it no you're doing so
much I've lived with guys before I just
haven't lived with guys that are as
obsessed with video games as math like I
thought I knew I'd had no idea well
isn't it funny to what quarantine will
bring out and people like you start
noticing things a little bit more than
you did before because you're around
each other so much
so have there been any pet peeves that
have been kind of brought to the
forefront during this period of self
isolation for the two of you
I know I've experienced my partner right
now we're so like on edge with each
other like you can just breathe the
wrong way and I'm like can you shut up
so she can whistle really high-pitched
so like when she's like whistling a tune
or something like it's just like it's
super high patient when I'm sitting on
at the counter working it's like are you
whistling so can you stop and I'm like
stop yeah I'm working from home and vice
but I like having somewhere to go I
really miss working I'm not gonna yes so
what's keeping you busy on the work
front yeah Rona there are a couple
restaurants I was working at one is a
really fantastic steakhouse in Buckhead
called a little alley and I bartend or
cocktail at a bar called supply and
demand which is also like just really
two fantastic places to work and that
was keeping me pretty busy like I was
taking classes so really around the
country you guys are there but the
restaurant business is really yeah
that's really scary
honestly I am obviously Matt's like
taking the brunt of all of it right now
and kind of
mostly carrying us I got my last two
paychecks today so hopefully yeah I got
my last two paychecks today I got all my
bills paid up so hopefully that'll last
till next month and korone will be over
by then otherwise you might have to
start shuffling some stuff around maybe
reignited your spark during this time
obviously we can all get on each other's
nerves from time to time because
everything is just heightened but
sometimes so is the love you know hmm
I'm just not feeling it but that's real
whistles she got going on your mother
okay so I did find okay you you ever
seen Vampire Diaries like the like they
bite the wrist for the blood yeah yeah
so I I was like maybe that's like
sensual or something like he was messing
around one day just like picking him
prodding and poking at me because he was
bored are you started like sucking at my
wrists and I'm like huh I mean it worked
for The Vampire Diaries yes wow that's
kind of he was like what do you like he
likes those young adult novels okay
where you just mentioned that Matt's
parents watching these interviews so
don't you know divulge a little too much
and how are the parents how are the
families kind of like intermingling now
that you guys Oh fantastic
didn't I got a card from his mom or from
both of his parents technically at forum
I know I opened it and I go oh my god
your mom absolutely was the one that
picked this
like I love his dad and I know you
really need to see it on this show but
we got to go to Italy and everything his
dad has a wonderful sense of humor I
told you Phil I would say it but his mom
and I are like you know we love having
mimosas together or like Bellinis and
stuff like that she's my drinking
partner and so like this card with a
picture of two girls like taking their
champagne flutes they're like I can't
remember which one of us is the bad
influence and I'm like this is so from
your mom your mom picked this out I knew
that I was like that's my partner in
crime right there out of being in pods
and doing a social experiment and
finding love with someone that you've
never seen in person you know that this
would all be happening but it is do you
feel like this sense of isolation is
it's taking it all back to the pods by
any means because it you kind of were
isolated you were sequestered during the
show not a hundred percent I think like
the fact that we have like still TV and
phones and everything like that that was
one thing we didn't have we have a lot
of us like in everyday like the TV and
the phone and the social media that help
distract you but in the pods like you
were so focused yes you died wouldn't
know what to do without like like I've
even even going through that entire
experience I wouldn't know what I would
be doing right now if I didn't have a
phone or TV you're in East Lake hey
watch it dry maybe ya ought to be
cleaning cleaning the house or something
we would actually be able to keep up
with Dakota hair
now you mentioned Italy so around this
time or so last year you guys
and shared some awesome pictures of
course on on the Instagram with your
fans and followers and things like that
what was that big trek like for the two
of you especially to go somewhere like
that as the newlywed couple so it was it
was amazing so I have like family from
Italy so he we were really went because
my parents wanted to celebrate my
grandmother who passed away right before
I went on the show and she's from Italy
she was born in tree s area and so we
went to go visit family like her family
up there and so it was like we just made
it an adventures like two weeks where we
just traveled and saw all the all the
sights is amazing and I thought it was
really cool there was the place where
his grandmother met his grandfather was
actually a castle and this grandfather's
unit was stationed at that castle and
back when I was enlisted I was attached
to the same unit that was stationed at
the castle where his met that it just
seems like coming full circle at that
point that you know I was a part of the
same unit that was the unit that got his
grandparents to me and well hopefully
maybe you guys can use this time to plan
your next big vacation we've got so many
we just made a board of things we're
gonna do all summer checklist like oh
gosh like so we want to spend a lot of
time outside sounds like whitewater
rafting kayaking we got the basics beach
obviously concerts festivals we really
miss festival we're gonna go back to
where we filmed in Mexico oh yeah we're
gonna go back to the hotel don't we
stayed I'm super excited about
do you guys happen to have babies on the
checklist
okay she's like a year from now like
look for look for announcements next hi
hey I don't know you're in here
nice nor god dang it I gotta stop doing
that Ike I told myself was like wasn't
gonna do that too like this second at
their date well it was cute so well
thank you you guys are pretty close with
the blind cast members during this
lately a lot probably Lauren and Cameron
yeah and they pretty much the rest of
the couples that are like in the same
situation that we are right now with
dealing with social media I know what
are you guys do in life because nobody
really understands how to handle this
really yeah I think I've talked to mark
I tried to play call of duty last night
two nights ago with mark he was doing
great like really great in his job or I
know can you imagine Oh see that's
that's what like the people that are
like we're in the pods that
end up married they're redoing that now
I guess few text messages and oh yeah
we're done we're not they got thrown
back and stuff the people that were in
the pods that didn't get to get married
like oh hey we're dating through a wall
again basically taking singles and they
are sending them to this resort retreat
and the point of this competition is to
not have sex for the entire month so the
longer you can hold out having intimacy
with another contestant the more money
you can walk away with so what advice
would you give these participants these
contestants that are getting ready to go
through what you guys have been through
especially on the fame front bring a lot
of lotion no I was like you bring a lot
of luck she likes too much from the guys
perspective self-love okay
I can't say that I have much advice
because we would have failed if that was
the premise of our
no idea I can't I can't imagine life
without you okay cuz you're stuck not
handling the fame that will come from
being a part of reality show on Netflix
that's one nice lie I'm just gonna say I
really hope they had the strong support
system like people that know you and
remind you of who you are because
there's gonna be a lot of people trying
to tell you who you are and what you're
about so you know you keep people around
I can bet know the truth
I guess people like to take like a
thirty minute segment of who you are and
make it into who you really are so and
then they like television caricature of
your personality and make it your
reality and that's for you yeah human
beings are not that simple we're a lot
more complex than that so I just make
sure that you have can help remind you
and keep you grounded wild I love it we
enjoyed it so much I'm like wina season
to you happening do you guys have any
scoop on it uh we're at the bottom of
the food chain here we know nothing
about nothing I know you casting I don't
even know if they're still casting I
don't know what's going on with the
whole situation but their thing and for
Chicago I think anybody in Chicago
that's looking to go on it by the way
there is no charge to apply for love is
blind I had a lot of people ask me about
that you don't pay anything to get on
the show for the record Thanks so on a
serious note you know warranty is
happening there are a lot of people
being affected
you know obviously in a more significant
way than I was thinking about okay
however in fact I'm ready and everything
is there anyone anything that you would
like to say on folks that are fighting
Kovac 19 on the front lines for all of
it
thank you no but thank you I have always
said that people that work in health
care it takes a very special soul to
dedicate your life to helping others
like that and especially in times like
this where you're not just dedicating
your life you're risking your life for
them and that's it's an amazing thing
and it's an amazing quality in a human
being so thank you okay well I've got a
little quarantine zoom round for you so
basically it's like a lightning round of
questions
oh I don't know makes me nervous when he
can't be filtered let's do this okay
just really simple questions guys what
is your go-to quarantine look like
Wardrobe onesies naked all naked I like
to just a t-shirt okay but if you do
guys if you see someone walking the
Atlantic Atlanta streets in a onesie
it's probably these two right if you see
somebody in a pokeymon Wednesday it
about Pokemon windy it's a hundred
percent yeah oh my gosh okay biggest
quarantine mishap or struggle I have one
for sure I had to run to the store the
other day and I threw on some pants
doing a t-shirt and I got back and I
realized I was wearing my pants
backwards not inside-out but backwards
[Music]
he was cooking dinner the other night
yeah you put a frying pan in the oven
which normally is okay yeah it doesn't
have plastic and it sounds like yeah you
can put the cast iron in there and he
pulls it out with a mitt and then a few
seconds later he touches the handle and
burns his hand like I was like well I
took I was cooking salmon I took the
same and off the thing and then I was
like okay I'm gonna throw this in the in
the sake real quick so wash it off and
get it soaking right and whatever I
grabbed the thing like five seconds
after I took the same entire all right
let's see what shows are you currently
binging
uh flash for me because it's Matt's
favorite show and I've never really like
kept up with it like sequentially so I'm
trying to catch up on that community you
just came out on Netflix tried watching
Tiger King only got an episode whoa
watch the whole thing because it's so
crazy
fully involved in time you break it in
there yeah that's pretty much that's
pretty much all we haven't watched
anything too serious it's hard she likes
scary movies I found out the other day
like she spent a whole day watching
scary movies no terrible talib terrible
terrible super corny scary movies like
they're really bad like be level B film
movies that don't go straight to beef
they go straight to DVD like okay what
was your last neg or guilty quarantine
pleasure Cheetos
I was eating them while I was driving to
the store like I keep a bag of Cheetos
in Michael they're my roads that's not a
snack that's a daily staple now
seriously we I I think we've had to like
restock our wine and beer supply like
I'm glad that liquor stores are
considered essential yes I think you are
not alone I think a lot of people across
the country feel the same way
what about is are there any new hobbies
or activities that you guys have taken
up since being in quarantine no I
haven't taken up one hobby specifically
but I've been doing like little artisan
crafts around the house like putting
Stoppers under our couch so could as
toys don't roll under or like rehanging
things or like painting things or sewing
buttons small little tasks like that
that I wouldn't normally do on a daily
basis it's not a new hobby but it is
it's a reimbursing yeah because it was
not something that it really was it like
I have learned a lot about him in Call
of Duty lately don't mess with me when
I'm in the gulag and finally can you
guys show us 180 or 360 of the room that
you're in right now we're in the corner
for a reason oh good lighting art in our
apartment and we've kind of like just
shoved everything into the middle of
before so we've been getting rods which
I didn't expect
but there's yeah well thank you so much
for your time today I really appreciate
it you guys are a fun
and stay safe and stay healthy and you
know don't listen to well thank you much
call of duty we make zero promises for
that
[Music]